the poster girl for overwatch herself
tracer actually one of the trickier
characters to get into here with our
overwatch hero guides I'm Chris waters
joined by Mike McCarty and we are gonna
tell you folks how to get started with
speeding arounds manipulating time and
filling your opponents full of little
little tiny bullets she's a deceiving
character because you don't want to just
necessarily be killing people she can
but that's not her main focus
my main focus my play tracer is to annoy
people stop them from getting to the
objective distract them take out their
offensive characters who are just as
mobile as maged all in all try to make
life difficult they have a team and that
is a hugely important strategic
consideration in overwatch keeping
enemies off the point stringing out
their team so they don't arrive at the
point in a group because one or two of
them are off trying to chase you down as
tracer these are all really valuable
ways to destabilise to damage and
ultimately defeat the other teams so
let's start with her pulse pistols she
dual wields him they shoot out like a
ton of little blue bees and then she has
to reload the main way I think about
those they're just kind of these rocks
you threw out the other team from a
distance you're saying hey I'm over here
come Chase me you run into a room even
if it's just them like as simple as
getting that red mark to pop up on their
screens like oh someone's hitting is
from behind what was that
they're gonna come chase you you're
gonna get their lucio who's giving them
the movement speed buff up to the
objective off course you're gonna pull
that attention and keeping that
attention is key for tracer also
avoiding that attention once you have it
is key because tracer does not have a
ton of health and this is where her
other her primary ability comes into
play
blink she can zip from place to place
and this is super important for playing
your role blink pretty much negates
choke points for tracer if you're coming
up on that first big gate and Hani
mourra and everybody else has it clogged
up it doesn't matter
boost boost boost and you're already
behind the team maybe even in the
objective she's great for getting to the
objective flitting around dodging people
annoying them letting the rest of the
team come up and help her she's not a
tank but she can evade almost anything
that is such a great strategy for
breaking those early blockades at choke
points you get on the point enough until
they start coming and then you get off
the point because you're not holding
that thing down by yourself but you've
now broken up the blockade and you are
ready to resume your role of harrying
them all over the place now her other
time shifting related ability is called
recall
and this is the one that's kind of gonna
save your butt when you're in trouble or
allow you to do a kind of overextend
move a dangerous move and then recover
from it I don't use this until it's my
last resort because our blink recharge
is pretty fast but this is the one that
takes a little longer recall also
recharges your health so it's even
better of a get-out-of-jail-free card
because you can revert back to an
earlier point in time and surprise
you're healthy again you can get into an
objective zone escape and then realize
the rest your team's there revert back
there
drop her sticky bomb and then get out of
there again it's just like the fact that
she is removing the rules of time and
space makes her such a hard character to
learn but such a hard character to deal
with from the enemy's perspective and
that sticky bomb you're talking about is
tracers ultimate the pulse bomb which
actually is one of the more frequently
refilling Ultimates in the game so you
don't want to save this one until the
perfect moment you can use this to stick
it to a big tank who is locking down the
objective you can use it to throw down
in front of people who are charging in
on your capture point you can use it to
blow up a bastion or Torbjorn encampment
and let your team get safe passage
through there the sticky bomb is almost
weird to call an ultimate because it's
not that powerful so you want to think
of it more as just this grenade that
refills pretty frequently throw it on
anything like throw it in the middle of
a few people throw it when you're not
even sure is gonna kill them just use it
as much as you can because she's so
mobile that you don't want to be stuck
for too long waiting for that perfect
moment to throw it and every time you do
it just raises your threat profile and
makes your power to distract the enemy
and draw their attention and get them
off the point and get them all jumbled
up it makes that even more powerful now
in terms of who you want to target when
you're running around you don't spend a
ton of time trying to focus on a tank
you want to try to take out those
supports you know yours in yatta is your
mercy's these are the people who it's up
to you to take down even a Widowmaker if
you can get around and flank her once
you're on top of her you can make pretty
quick worker for a blink or two and you
are have taken out their sniper she's
just great for mind games - she can get
around the side when there's a McCree or
a Reaper coming up to flank your team
she can annoy them and draw them off the
path she can also get behind it in place
Bastion turret she can shoot at it it
turns around it's not looking at your
team anymore
it's all about convincing your enemy
that there are two fronts they're
fighting on even if the one behind them
is not that much of a threat the best
tracers you see in play against are so
annoying and they will kill you a bunch
but you don't have to be that
best tracer when you start out you just
need to be that annoying need to be
drawing that attention and you need to
be darting around causing chaos all with
a smile on your face thanks for
listening to our overwatch hero guides
folks we've got more in the series be
sure to check out the full playlist on
GameSpot's youtube channel and subscribe